the modern warfare series has always
been about the messiness of modern war
the fundamentally different rules of
engagement that come with a battle that
has no set battlefields when the fight
could be anywhere at any time where do
you draw the line between doing what's
right and doing what has to be done
throughout call of duty modern warfare
campaign that line is chemical weapons
it's a safe line to draw people are
largely in agreement that chemical
weapons are beyond horrific but there
are other horrors of war some of which
modern warfare depicts starkly and
strong but uncomfortable missions just
when it could really make a point about
any other aspect of modern war it pulls
back modern warfare makes old
observations and presents them with new
flourishes those new flourishes do make
for a good campaign and solid
multiplayer but is when modern warfare
asks you to think harder that it falls
short
in one of the game's most distressing
levels you play as Farah
a young girl in a fictional war-torn
Middle Eastern country as she hides from
both a Russian terrorist and the deadly
gas his cohorts have been leashed on her
town to escape you have to kill a man
twice your size with his own gun
it's a deeply uncomfortable experience
but the flashback serves to illustrate
why Farah now the leader of a group of
freedom fighters refuses to use chemical
weapons or associate with anyone who
does it is a hard line she won't cross
even though she's had to face a lot of
ugliness in the course of defending her
country in many ways Farah is Modern
Warfare's moral compass there are a few
key players in Modern Warfare's proxy
war and everyone you play as sergeant
Kyle Garrick from the UK rogue American
soldier Alex echo 3-1 and sometimes
Farah herself abides by her one rule
outside of that though the rules are
much murkier in getting pulled into a
war between the Russian terrorists a
separatist group from Forrest country
and the freedom fighters themselves US
and UK military personnel disagree on
how to best proceed with the situation
matters of disobeying orders sacrificing
some lives to save others taking
civilian hostages and even torture and
on these matters the moral compass is
captain price
a returning face from the original
modern warfare and undeniably a
problematic fave captain price is the
seasoned badass who takes the lead in
most Garrick missions early levels with
price are among the best they range from
large-scale high-octane firefights to a
carefully planned raid on a terrorist
hideout with less than a dozen enemies
total price guides you through the
different approaches you need for each
mission and his mentorship both in the
mechanical skills you need to be
successful and the hard choices you have
to make along the way makes these
missions memorable while Alex's missions
don't stick out quite as much in a
gameplay sense he gets a sniping level
reminiscent of the original Modern
Warfare's all Gallade up but with more
enemies and otherwise a few cool gadgets
his dynamic with fara is strong though
he follows for his lead on her turf and
on her terms because he believes in the
cause and they share mutual respect it's
disappointing though that fara doesn't
play more of a role while she is a key
part of Alex's missions and the driving
force behind much of the story he only
plays her a few times on top of the
childhood flashback there is an even
more disturbing flashback later on in
which you see the full extent of far as
resolve experiencing her suffering this
way borders on unnecessary and it's
already established in Alex's missions
that she's a respected leader and a
strong-willed person in general while I
liked Alex I would have rather just
played as Farah in those missions then
get to know her character largely
through her trauma while modern warfare
raises difficult questions in the end it
fails to interrogate them further all
you get is a vague we all did what we
had to do sentiment rather than anything
more substantial or interesting the
ending isn't bad but it is a safe one
leaving you to think on the harder
questions for yourself why if we got our
hands tied
just take the bloody gloves off a fight
if anything modernwarfare let's fara
down with the bizarre and much-discussed
inclusion of white phosphorus as a
killstreak in multiplayer given how
strong the campaign's emphasis is on
chemical weapons being a reprehensible
war crime it's tone-deaf to include one
in multiplayer
[Music]
outside of any somatic contradictions
Modern Warfare's multiplayer is up to
par with a variety of game types for
different kinds of players realism mode
is undeniably the highlight it's
somewhere between the familiar core and
hardcore modes bridging the gap between
them oddly enough you can take more
damage than in hardcore and your health
regenerates like a dozen core but
realism removes the hood entirely going
beyond hardcore to strip out the kill
feed on top of everything else in order
to confirm a kill you have to listen for
the sound effect that plays upon death
it's a fantastic balance for those who
want more of a chance to survive a scrap
rather than dying in one or two shots
like in hardcore but with the rest of
the challenge intact it's a smart
satisfying evolution and there's a
stubborn hardcore only player it's one I
could see myself playing exclusively
going forward while none of the new game
types are earth-shattering some are
better additions than others TDM 2810
v10 version of the classic 6 v 16
deathmatch mode is the least inventive
or warranted of them instead functioning
as a more bloated version of regular TDM
with bigger maps that can make getting
back into the action in overly long
process one of the two maps I've tried
Euphrates bridge also suffers from
balance problems on top of that of the
two spawns one is much closer to the
bridge dividing the map and the closer
side was almost guaranteed victory in
every match I played gunfight is the
antithesis of TDM 20 it's a 1 life 2 V 2
mode in which your loadout rotates each
round and the goal is to kill your two
opponents with the means available to
you before they get you first with a
relatively level playing field battles
are often exhilaratingly close and it's
hard to get discouraged by a loss since
rounds go by so quickly
ground war is somewhere in the middle
maps are sprawling with five control
points to capture in one safe zone for
each team on either end
unlike in TDM 20 you can pretty easily
get back to the fight after dying by
responding at any capture point your
team owns four on two vehicles or your
teammates provided they're not actively
in a fight having objective points is
also helpful for keeping such a large
game type more structured than the
free-for-all of TDM that said matches
can drag on a bit too long as there
isn't anything to break up the constant
tug-of-war for capture points on paper
spec ops is a co-op mode where you and a
team complete a set of objectives and
are rewarded with some story you can
choose one of several roles at the onset
each with its own ultimate ability
there's a medic for instance that can
revive fallen teammates and as a group
you have to work together to overcome
enemies while gaining Intel heading to
specific objective points and so on in
practice though my team of four can
barely complete a handful of the
objectives on both of the missions we
attempted during the review event and it
only got marginally better as I
continued to play for the review this is
largely due to frustrating enemy
spawning enemies seem to generate
endlessly from all directions and it's
all too easy to get overwhelmed by them
to add insult to injury there are also
no clear waves it's just enemies from
everywhere at all times after struggling
to fight them off reviving each other as
we each inevitably died we would end up
running out of ammo and dying for good
experimentation in spec ops isn't
rewarded either trying different
strategies stealth dividing and
conquering new loadouts doesn't really
change how many enemies swarm you so
brute force ends up being the best way
to actually complete a mission even when
you do succeed you don't feel like you
got better you feel like you got lucky
cooperating with teammates largely comes
down to asking for revives or reviving
someone else in turn rather than
actually coordinating to improve your
chances of victory the ps4 exclusive
survival mode fares better it plays more
like zombies with kills converted into
dollars that you can use to buy upgrades
and it has traditional waves rather than
a barrage of enemies there's a brief
reprieve between each wave during which
you can upgrade your weapons refill ammo
or otherwise just steal yourself for the
next wave mini-boss like enemies appear
during specific waves too so
if you diet weigh five in one game you
can go into the next more prepared for
wave five armed with knowledge and a
more powerful gun the pitfalls of
SpecOps don't detract from what modern
warfare does well though realism mode is
an excellent addition to the slate and
although not all the new multiplayer
modes are great gunfight and the night
vision playlists are refreshing
standouts and while the campaign ends up
playing it safe in the end it's still a
memorable one and it lays a strong
foundation for where the modern warfare
series could go from here and you
keeping your word I don't do this to
keep my word
[Music]